oh my goodness you guys people of the
internet retro raconteur here we did it
man we did it we reached Grand Master as
a free to play player as you can see
here we actually ended on a six game
winning streak to do it I'm gonna break
down everything for you guys today I'm
gonna show you my deck that I used to
get here and then I'm gonna take you
through the last three games which were
all so incredibly hyped we actually
ended up getting matched up against
three grand Masters in route to getting
this we won all three of those games
against Grand Masters it was absolutely
epic all right so here is the deck that
we were running very very fortunate to
get a Bellatrix legendary Echo we
actually somehow did this at only
Spellbook level 38. I don't think we're
gonna be able to go much higher without
actually spending some money on this
game that's one of the unfortunate
things about the game as much as I love
it and I love it so much I actually want
to spend money on it now I want to
support these developers I just wish it
wasn't so closely tied to the PVP to
where you can really rank much higher
unless you're spending money on the game
I wish it was just it would just level
everything out in PvP I don't know why
it can't do that you know the cards
could still be things that you you know
pay for to get your keys and all that
but it is what it is man so the
Bellatrix Echo I was very fortunate to
get that out of a haunted hollow level
eight clear shout out to our social
Clubhouse rack and tour if you guys
haven't joined yet we have a second one
now as well check out our Discord in the
video description below but the
Bellatrix Echo I'll show you guys the
cards it dropped with it didn't really
have great cards here at the start at
least card I don't use these cards much
in PvP at all actually but it's my first
legendary I was like you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and fully upgrade it I
don't care I need this one to have
something and we ended up getting three
big time three Big Time Bomb box
absolutely huge huge to get bomb box
with a with a plus one boost Cornish
pixie with a plus one boost and then
Cassandra who you're about to see we
started using her as well
two boost on Cassandra so that was
really helpful to get the echo right
there
I added nebulous if you guys watched my
last video on the deck you'll see that
this one it changed up a little bit
there's several cards that I swapped out
once I hit Diamond I started running
into a lot more of the orb of water it
also just so happens that the Norwegian
Ridgeback card is banned when I was
making this run so that removed
atmospheric charm I didn't need to have
atmospheric charm so I added this one
instead esposo is great for trying to
knock people out of the orb of Water
cast it's going to help you get out of
that it's really really helpful and then
the cats man I had to add these cats I
just kept running into more and more of
these and they're so annoying to deal
with because you kill one and then just
more come and those paired with the bomb
box is huge it's huge but I didn't want
to lose my monster book and I didn't
want to lose the Pixies I think the
Pixies are actually a little bit
underrated if you get Pixies going with
bomb box they can even do a decent job
against an opal eye or something and
then I also added nebulous because right
now The Meta in my region has just been
all about thunderstorm all about
thunderstorm
and honestly like you could debate
nebulous because a lot of people they
just instantly use something to get you
out of the nebulous so they might use
exploso they might use incendio to make
you burn if you're gonna sit in there or
they could use like a port key some
people were running that you could throw
a monster book in there there's a lot of
ways to break the nebulous unfortunately
however I do still think it's worth it
for those times where maybe somebody
throws this out of desperation they're
out of MP
then you drop the nebulous and you're
just going to be protected from that
Cassandra I added her because the higher
and higher I got I started to notice
more and more people weren't using Ron
in that first slot like so many are in
gold and uh Platinum
Cassandra is so strong against anything
that's spamming a lot of little minions
to attack you even the opal eye
Cassandra will do a good job against the
Opel eye you just have to knock the
opalai into her little ring using
something like esposo so monster book is
a fantastic card fantastic card it's
really fast you see I got mine up to
level 10 which is huge and then I got
the bomb box to level 10 plus one
because of the echo I mean I don't think
people need to know any more about the
bomb box everybody knows how strong that
card is pairing that I mean all these
these four right here just pair so
incredibly well together incendio I feel
like is a must to deal with any kind of
ads that are surrounding you if you get
surrounded by like a stack of Monster
books or something like the cats or if
the opal eye does get in too close there
are a lot of situations where incendio
is going to be great for you and then
because I'm running the Bella six Echo
I eventually had to add thunderstorm
myself I took out the stack of Monster
books although I still really like that
card I think you can make a good
argument for that one too unfortunately
it costs one more MP plus with the
lightning I can go Hermione I can go
Hermione in that second slot so roughly
Midway through the fight I try to time
it to where maybe they've just used a
nebulous
and I know they're out of it though
Hermione throw the double thunderstorm
it's just really really really powerful
and then Hagrid in the last spot a lot
of times at the end of a fight you're
starting to run out of Mobility your
health is really low and Hagrid gives
you both of those things it also just so
happens that I was able to get my
Haggard up to a level 10. so it worked
out very nicely that he was my companion
here so getting that little bit of extra
Health Plus the extra Mobility that
Hagrid gives you can be super clutch and
also protects you from a number of
different attacks so that is pretty much
what we were running let's dive into
some games now and you guys can see how
these last three went which all three of
them were so incredibly hype it was
absolutely insane all right so let's
take a look at the first match here
which was against a grand master using
Snape and I did not think I was going to
win this fight you guys I was just in
admiration I was kind of in awe of the
style of a Snape User it's it's really
really interesting
so you can see they start off with I can
already tell they're going to be using
that accio a lot because they want to
pull me in close
I'm trying to get rid of Kevin as fast
as I can
because that is the last thing we need
and then of course any Snape is going to
be running a Time Turner
so that was actually a really good job
the monster book right there
that was huge and then we almost have
his first
it's about to call it an echo I mean I
guess it's like a a clone we almost
defeated the first clone and finally get
it right there Cassandra's still up for
us which is good but I mean right now
we're down a thousand HP
right there that was huge man that was
huge really good damage from the Death
Eater right there
and at this point I kind of just have to
concede Cassandra he pulls me in again
with accio
which I mean he was just like just
ripping me with that sectum simpra
so I'm still down about 400 but that was
a big push right there by me thanks to
the Death Eater
all right so I'm like okay I don't think
I've seen him use nebulous yet and then
of course he has a nebulous
I go ahead and use the monster book so
at least he's gonna take some bolts from
it
then he throws out Ron
I try and protect protect Cassandra with
nebulous I get it Death Eaters spawn at
the perfect time
the perfect time he pulls me in again
with accio I was feeling pretty
comfortable right there he pulls me on
with the accio though and it just starts
shredding me
I don't know why I use the bombtastic
bomb right there that was probably a
really bad play I fire the monster
because I see his health so low I'm like
I need to get that monster book right on
him
and then I just get the cat going I know
I've got the HP Advantage I just gotta
Outlast him and we did we did but man
props incredible player that's a style I
actually really want to experiment with
is playing Snape and running the time
Turner so fun oh and excuse me it looks
like that player was not a grand master
the Snape user we did play another
person who was a Snape Grand Master
right before that now let's go ahead and
take a look at another grand master user
running a Bellatrix legendary see how
this fight goes is basically Bellatrix
legendary versus Bellatrix legendary
here
and I'm telling you man all three of
these final fights were so ridiculously
close remember draft of Peace though I
was comfortable I was like even if I
lose not the end of the world again we
were at a disadvantage HP wise here he
throws out the bomb I've got monster
book and then really early use on the
companion right there so I go ahead and
bring out Cassandra I I should say early
for Malfoy gang
I'm not real sure what the thought
process was right there maybe try to get
them going with the bombs
so then Cassandra helps me take them out
and then he he takes her out pretty
quick too unfortunately so both
companions are down
I know he's not running a Fred Fred and
George or anything because of the meter
which
I ran into a couple of Fred and George's
I think I lost to both of them too on
this run
and right here I've already got the
Pixies out so we're kind of just letting
the MP build letting him deal with the
Pixies right now
I hate when I don't have bombs on the
field
so I see he throws that I've gotta
immediately get rid of the bomb box now
I'm in big trouble we got bomb box plus
the stack
we get him with incendio and then we
also get a Death Eater
Death Eater is going to help me finish
off that monster book now he gets his
Death Eater too
look at the cats though
look at the cats working on the Death
Eater they're just so annoying to deal
with do you see that move by me right
there I know my camera is kind of
blocking it a little bit but I kind of
did this little Dodge
oh my gosh
oh my gosh that was so much damage right
there yeah I did this little uh I
actually took the nebulous Cloud the
aggro away from the Death Eater because
the Death Eaters you guys are powerful
but they're not very smart man
Mary's is smart they'll just walk right
through all sorts of Hazards so I could
see he was about to walk right by it we
get two Death Eaters on the field now
another stack of Monster books but we
got the Death Eaters to help I decide to
save the incendio
I see he's got bomb box over there I've
got to take out the bomb box that's why
I sent the monster book over which
unfortunately it didn't actually even
get it that was a wasted incendio right
there I got a little greedy
got a little greedy trying to end the
fight you can see he's still like
running around trying to deal with the
cats so I think hey let's just throw a
bomb box
now I'm feeling pretty good but watch
look look how much I'm up watch how
close he comes to pulling this back
what a push this was
he sends Ron he sends the stack he sends
two Death Eaters I do expulso and it has
it doesn't help look at that man I'm
getting Zapped by both of them I
actually thought it was over
I actually thought I was over because I
know how much power those stat leaders
have Hagrid's already done now finally I
get my Death Eaters and I'm like I just
got a retreat I got a retreat I got a
retreat he and I knew I had heard a
thunderstorm let me get in the nebulous
and now it's just 1v1 man it's 1v1 with
me having a pretty good Advantage but he
sends out the stack now I had to make a
decision I've got incendio do I go for
him I did
took him down to 121.
I still don't know if it was the right
call or if I should have just finished
off the books in front of me but then I
I I'd love to tell you guys that I knew
the time was ticking and so that's why I
wanted to do more damage but the truth
is I was so into the fight I wasn't even
paying attention to the time it worked
out very well I did know that I had him
at much lower Health than I was and so I
just needed to buy as much time as I
could with those Monster books and keep
inflicting whatever damage I could
alright then we have our final match
here this was the match to get to Grand
Master this was against a fellow Diamond
Player and they were running a Hermione
deck and this is one where I look almost
very very even 3125 to 30 55. this is
one that I almost lost I got I get ahead
pretty pretty comfortably here in a
minute
and then they do an incredible job of
nearly bringing it back
so you can see we're kind of playing the
game right now of thunderstorm trying to
get the other one out
I get the bombs going
so they cast thunderstorm with Hermione
I know I've gotta prevent some of this
damage
that was that was a great play by them
I finally break us out of it with
expulso but a lot of the damage is done
so that completely eliminated Cassandra
fortunately we got Hermione too
so he's got a 400 HP Advantage right
there
and just made it even more with that a
pug no pug knows a little bit underrated
I feel like man
pugno plus the broom and then I don't
have nebulous right here so I'm just
throwing out all the support to try and
help spread the damage around
we got a Death Eater on the field
I know this Death Eater is probably not
going to do much because he's he's
trapped in there
I do the incendio to force him out
though and look what happens look what
happens
I feel like people underestimate the
Death Eaters like I don't know
he chose to kind of fly away
which I get why he did it but
so we get caught in the orb I fire the
exploso to get out and he's still just
like ignoring the Death Eater I don't
know
I know they don't have a lot of help but
people just ignore them too much
nebulous to break a little bit of the
damage he gets the incendio on me I have
to move now look at this I got a I mean
not a huge lead but I got a fairly
comfortable lead he also has Cassandra
going though
now I get the Death Eater but he gets
oh no he didn't get it in orb of water
look at this man I'm up a thousand to
300 or so
and then he oh that was nice play right
there by him he gets rid of both the
Death Eaters
I wasn't out of move so I don't know if
I misclicked right there or what
now look how close it is
now look how close it is he gets run out
so I've got to bring out Hagrid
trying to get rid of Ron here just just
trying to
fight for my life and get Ron off the
field that's my main focus we get
another thunderstorm I go to the back
corner that was a misplay right by him
right there that incendio I bet he
wishes he would have held it but now
look how close it is look how close it
is
oh my
gosh it was so ridiculously close when
he did the epug note I thought I was
done
I thought I was done when he did the
epug note plus the broomstick but what
an absolutely Epic Journey it was in
fact I streamed it live right here on
YouTube I'll link to that whole stream
here on the right side of your screen
check that one out next as always guys
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon